schio la manchester d'italia ho letto è
vero
certo tra tante città vado manchester
gap quella operaia un po new york
sarebbe stata uguale
comunque ci accontentiamo allora io ho
il compito del risveglio post prandiale
che la cosa che mi accompagna la serve
il comico purtroppo un miserabile e
l'ultimo delle ruote del carro che il
comico alle sagre è quello che fa lo
spettacolo mentre mangia la gente ai
matrimoni pizzerie ed è mai visto un
concerto di giovanni allevi durante la
cena e dopo bollani oppure una
retrospettiva dei che slow ski durante
la sagra non pensano il comico si perché
quello che pensa che deve far svegliare
la gente
e voi mi odiate questo momento visivo le
coast ancora un po a dormire ma io
conosco schio anche perché ho iniziato
quasi la mia carriera qui perché gigi
ragazzi dell'organizzazione
adesso lui è serio non può fare non può
dire che sta parte quindi
l'organizzazione non può però mi ha
invitato a nessuno le conosceva proprio
cerio primo quante persone 150 forse
forse meno di 50 è a schiemer e non che
abbiamo ce ne fossero di più ci sono 20
a bergamo una volta acquaviva delle
fonti vicino bari erano 7 era un
compleanno tra l'altro nero maturo
spettatori proprio perciò invitato io
alla loro mensa e quindi un po di tempo
è passato e loro sanno gli scriventi
scledensi scledensi beh comunque come ho
fatto non arrivarci subito alla scusa al
co dove a scrivo in merito sanno prima
degli altri quello che è successo in
questo paese l'italia per la comicità
molti non lo sanno ancora non lo sanno
ma la comicità d'italia avuto una sorta
di paese può allenato dell'arte non si
tratta per cento delle opere d'arte
stanno qui la cultura il rinascimento
tutto per la comicità noi abbiamo avuto
una sorta di oscurantismo la comicità
l'italia è rimasta al palo a quella che
era cominciata negli anni 50 nella va
spettacolo non sono conosciute lava
spettacolo alberto sordi totò
beh in america negli anni 50 e la stessa
cosa
gli stati uniti subito vola guerra come
tutti i paesi del mondo avevano la
comicità fatta per intrattenere
semplicemente ridere per vivere perché
si veniva da una tragedia insieme alla
seconda guerra mondiale
la seconda guerra mondiale era una
ferita trasversale che aveva aperto il
cuore le membra dei famiglie intere
cecchino giardi un fratello che un
figlio che un marito chi la moglie
oppure aveva perso la casa e quando tu
vivi una docente del genere che posso
americane il francese italiano e inglese
ti unisci come un unico popolo come
l'unica persona un individuo che
abbracci e pensi che l'intrattenimento
serva solo esclusivamente per farti
evadere da quella tragedia quindi si
andava nei cabaret e c'era compagnia di
giro c'erano imitatori come lo faceva
parte letta due ballerine
e poi c'erano pestrin e il presentatore
e duro di trattenimento 17 non pensava
cioè vado lì per non pensare aveva un
senso culturalmente a livello culturale
l'artista era coerente col periodo stava
vivendo perché non poteva se sul palco
che faccio adesso è parlare di bergoglio
a nessuno interessava volevano stare
chiedeva del papa quando ce l'ho più la
cassa giusto poi però in america
cambiano le cose
l'america non è più quella società
ferita dalla guerra ma è una società che
diventa individualisti una società col
capitalismo che diventa una società
fatta di unici individui che lottano tra
di loro lo start la competizione proprio
nasce dalla scuola e si odiano le
persone tra di loro perché tutte quante
devono raggiungere l'obiettivo e gli
altri sono i nemici e questa società
americana non è più di fratelli ma di
mezzo la società fatta di persone sole
il comico se ne accorge e un certo lenny
bruce non so se conoscete
ecco infatti è per questo che sono qui
le di blues cabarettista barzellettiere
decide di raccontare invece che la
barzelletta dice di raccontare la storia
di due professori del liceo scientifico
del massachusetts che sono stati
licenziati perchè omosessuali e lui dice
ma perché gli hanno licenziati
la licenziati perché erano scarsi o
perché stavano in bagno a farsi un
pompino vicenda il pubblico registe così
ha detto pompino sulla differenza di
schio le libros viene arrestato e
arrestato perché aveva fatto una cosa
sbagliatissima detto una parola fuori
dal mondo per la società di quegli anni
lui continuerà a fare della pubblicità
continua a essere arrestato ma da lì
parte una nuova comicità in tutto il
mondo diceva stand up comedy e cioè il
comico da solo sul palco che porta le
proprie miserie dove disgrazie porta la
propria vita disastrata perché comico e
più miserabili tutti gli individui ma
quella miseria e catartica per la gente
lo ascolta perché quella miseria anche
quella del pubblico perché l'america non
c'è più l'america che si vuole bene e le
miserie del comico sono i segnali dei kg
ma se ti cambia tutto il mondo francia
il terra
woody allen conoscete il kospi robbie
williams
chris lock eddy murphy jim carrey stand
up comedian tutti
travica l'italia l'italia rimane
completamente al palo resta con
l'avanspettacolo non c'è stata coveri in
italia condire i carrozzoni di comicità
come drive in zelig colorado made in sud
e cioè comici che fanno ridere per
ridere e si pensa che queste di gusti no
in realtà no ecco perché in italia e nel
mucchio nel mondo ci fosse di beatles
ovunque in italia fosse di marina pizzi
sempre l'immagine con adesso grazie dei
fior
in italia arrivano i beatles nella pizzi
prende microfono lo perde al chiodo si
cesa qualche vecchietta che ancorava
senti ma sono i beatles a livello che
roma in italia no
fino a quando fino a quando un manipolo
di pazzi nel 2010 fa una specie di nelle
catacombe romane dei locali si ritrova e
78 comici iniziano le comedy un paese
dove è lì che fa già 12 milioni
spettatori e tra questi ce l'ho anch'io
e tra questi c'era questo imbecille che
è venuta schio con 50 persone anche meno
ma poi al 2014
all'arrivo in televisione ed italia
cambia tutto chiude zelig e non esiste
più il cabaret in tutta italia adesso
c'era stata come ha detto avviso il
ragazzo annuisce losa capi con 13 17 17
anni sa perché lui è nato geneticamente
modificato dalla nuova comicità lui lo
conosce brignano conosce bellix tucci
bravo hai tu distrutto quello che ho
detto in pubblico a parte della velocità
però conosce la starna comodi ma la
conoscono in tanti perché non esiste più
comico in italia adesso che si traveste
e fa l'imitazione su tutti i comici sono
solo esclusivamente sembra come dire
tutti la sorprende il fatto dicendo
ancora tre o quattro che sono ai vertici
brignano pinto sistema questa è è
normale il senso hanno vita breve
brevissimo però esiste ancora c'è la
decadenza ma tutti come ci stanno
venendo adesso sono stata cabilia e non
è una questione di gusti e sui flussi no
questa questa conferenza
il flusso al latte è un flusso un fiume
inarrestabile che nessuno può
permetterci di cercare di arginare ci ha
provato hitler bruciando i libri non
penso che a schio ci riuscireste voi da
soli no è quindi ci si deve arrendere al
fatto che l'ha cominciata sta cambiando
e qual è la più grossa resistenza che si
incontra è il fatto che si va bene
questione di gusti
a me non piace ti piace brignano gusti
bene sono convinto che la musica voi
questa cosa non la fareste questo tipo
di positivo di banalizzazione se come
dice sì tra calcutta e calcutta non è la
città
un cantante da calcutta di andrea chi è
meglio calcutta tutti quanti direbbero
bene break tra sergio leone è un film di
vanzina quanti direbbe così posso anche
le nove del filo regia ma quanti dire
però ben vanzina mi piace di più il
senso le vuole perché questione di gusti
lo faresti se ce l'avete no perché
culturalmente abbiamo una sorta di
eredità genetica avevo culturale che ci
permette di distinguere tra una come una
sorta di arte magari data sgrosso quella
da fast food da mangiare subito come
film fracassoni oppure d'azione e poi un
cinema un certo livello per questo che
elio petri lo sarà mai
muccino è per questo che giorgio
montanini ormai brignano è una questione
come diceva questo e spocchioso c'era di
questa stessa cosa di sergio leone
no no e io sto qui oggi pro per dirvi
questo il fatto che culturalmente questo
paese sia indietro non consente al
pubblico di pensare che io possa essere
paragonato a player o che la strada coma
di possa essere paragonata lava
spettacolo come questione di gusti e
sapete perché perché c'è una coerenza
artistica e culturale che va rispettata
chi la rispetta stai dietro tipo piacere
della pc prost ai 70 didietro regista di
beatles se adesso però cercherò quindi
vi faccio un esempio bellissimo che a
cena il bisbetico domato conoscevano il
film con adriano celentano ornella muti
per far capire al pubblico guarda il
film quanto celentano fosse al di fuori
del contesto sociale e culturale di quel
paese perché lui non parlava nessuno
parlava con gli uccelli come san
francesco ma non parlava con la gente
per quanto lui fosse eremita a livello
culturale sociale fanno un sano la
comicità e cioè guardano le comiche
insieme celentano ornella muti
e c'è la classica buccia di banana la
torta in faccia
ornella muti ride celentano piange e
dice ma scusa è caduto quel signore io
mi fa pena ma è la comicità c'è la base
la comicità la torta in faccia la buccia
dei banali signore ben vestito salire e
lui piange s'incazza perde va via e
uscendo dalla stanza scivola per le
scale e sulla gamba lui si alza la vede
con la gamba lotta dire che fa cioè mai
detto che quando uno cade a bisogna
ridere che voleva di pratiche se tu non
condividi un immaginario culturale
sociale con il pubblico e il comico non
lo convince il comico non lo condivide
col pubblico il pubblico non lo
condivide con il comico non si ride
quindi se non siamo sullo stesso piano e
non condividiamo lo stesso immaginario
culturale
non possiamo ridere tra noi che possiamo
divertirci ecco adriano celentano non
poteva divertire con nessun tipo di
comicità perché neanche quella base la 0
era faceva parte del suo immaginario
quindi non è questione di gusti non è
questione di voglio ridere per ridere
a me interessa a ridere per vivere non è
il momento
quel momento in passato perché per
ridere per ridere c'è il comico più
bravo volete il comico più bravo vi
faccia dire è la macchina per il
solletico me l'avete di sotto le ascelle
è quella vi fa scoppiare le coronarie
per quello di far vivere e quelle
avviene per vivere però come jimi
hendrix non si terrà per schitarrare
bene anche sergio leone registravano di
registrare fa già riguardato renò
l'artista esprime un proprio bisogno una
propria esigenza l'artista utilizza la
risata per veicolare un pensiero
consiglio fa il regista così lo fa il
musicista quindi il fatto che voi
considerate la risata il fine del comico
è perché la comicità in italia non ha il
giusto riconoscimento culturale siete
ignoranti
in questo momento sono più eccitato che
se ci fosse bella ere d'irrigazione
anche a me perché il gusto del comico è
proprio quello di infilare uno stiletto
propone i vostri nervi scoperti
l'ignoranza non vi consente di poter
pensare che la risata si è il mezzo
attraverso il quale poter distinguerla
propone un comico o no la risata è solo
il mezzo non è il fine del comico come
non erano gli accordi di jimi hendrix
usava la musica per esprimerci decidevi
criminalizzare la risata
no la risata non devi mai
criminalizzarle mai perché la ricetta è
come se fosse una sorta di martelletto
che va sul sulle ginocchia non è un
riflesso si ride io dico con tutti gli o
con banfi boldi balls a commissario nido
ma se tu con dvd un immaginario
culturale sociale e di chiedere perché
rido e allora sai che metti la risata
per dinho banti qui e per lenny bruce
qui grazie
[Applauso]